you had sent us an email I guess we're
on your email list and so you don't send
out emails too often I think you do it
kind of sparingly and you had an article
in one of them that's the title was
surround yourself with people who hold
you to a higher standard than you hold
yourself
and so we're kind of just that lends
itself perfectly what does that mean for
you
it means it's easy to be around a whole
bunch of people that are miserable and
you know frustrated with their careers
and so they will tend to be in their own
stuff and so I try to do my best to
surround myself around people that are
trying to better themselves that are
doing the risky things that I want to be
doing so that when I can when I'm
feeling down I can call them and say for
example I just had breakfast with a
writer producer friend of mine who's on
a TV show and I had sent him an email
sand is so funny he didn't even remember
responding to the email that was sweat
like it's just his life is so busy Ken
thinks it but he responded but I had
said so I have this pilot that I wrote I
got a ton of notes from people I did
those notes I feel really good about it
then I got notes from this one person
and it's sort of a rewrite like bigger
rewrite but I have in my process I got
this other idea and I'm thinking this
other idea is better than this other
pilot so do I do this rewrite on the
pilot or should I start working on the
new show and so he wrote back oh man how
many times I have been in this position
finished rewriting the pilot then go to
the new story and so it was that kind of
thing and then he had sent an email
couple weeks later
hey checking in did you start working on
the pilot and he totally forgot he
checked in he forgot that he had
remembered after I told him but it
wasn't something like he was walking in
but so for me trying to surround myself
with people that hold themselves to a
higher you know calling and higher you
know a sort of responsibility that
helped me and so and that's how I am
with my friends I'm you know I studied
with Milton Katselas at Beverly Hills
Playhouse and one of the things he used
to say when people were late to class he
would say
you got horrible friends in this class
to the person that walked in and usually
usually the person like what do you mean
looks like well I find your friend I
would have like walked out you know
before you got here and called you and
say where are you why aren't you here
your friends aren't holding you
accountable they're not helping you and
so that was always something that like
you know that I want to try to be he
said
it's more difficult to do that with
friends and you can potentially lose a
friend because your music are you
willing to lose a friend to help them
and to help them be better and I think
that's what you know I try to be I'm not
perfect with it they're prime sure
there's friends of mine that I should I
could push more or support more and at
the same time you know I'm not doing
everything I should be doing you know
I'm not saying I'm perfect but I'm
saying that how I can support and uplift
some people around me you know it's I
think it's important he's just I think
it's my default is not to take action my
default is really to you know find
what's wrong with what I'm doing and
sort of just stay in this like hamster
wheel of like it's not working I don't
know what to do how do I figure it out
and that's why what that Wallach before
it handled this project so I sit there
and go trying to figure out how it was
gonna get the right person to read this
script or you know take this meeting
instead of just going okay I have this
project now what are the actions I can
take okay here's the emails of these
five people done do these things great
alright so I did that and then what else
gonna do today I guess I'll go to the
beach or go have lunch or you know my
wife and I will go do something or now
it's like oh right I have my hour and a
half they do something and then he's up
and it's like okay you got him no okay
great Alfie I got well let me just play
the devil's advocate here because um I
think it's great that you have that
desire to want to be around people that
are gonna hold you to a higher standard
or maybe they're further along but then
there's this thing in LA where sometimes
when people do achieve things it's
almost like a magnet and then people go
away and they get kind of like left to
their own devices
because maybe they're not at the same
level and they feel bad about themselves
you threatened so find that interesting
that you want to surround yourself with
either people they're gonna hold you
accountable or maybe people that have
maybe a few more credits or whatever and
you feel like that's beneficial because
I don't know if everybody thinks that
way and I hate to take a negative turn
with it no but I think that's a very big
thing in this town oh yeah I mean I feel
like there's a there's a lot of people
that you know don't want people to be
successful that means they feel very
limited that's my limit I feel like it's
limited to think that if you get
something that means that I that there's
nothing left for me if you get that
thing because there's just so many
there's so many opportunities there's
enough work for everybody there's enough
for everybody and so I think it's hard
for people because you're fighting for
you know even asking for help from
somebody I mean it's hard to ask for
somebody to go okay can you introduce me
to so-and-so that you know if I'm trying
to get a project with that person that's
it so that that happens a lot and so
sometimes it's like oh yeah that's an
easy thing and other time just like I
know you have a project it's very
similar to mine so I am no situation I
will usually be honest and say if it's
something like that I'll say listen I
would love to but right now I have this
project and I'm trying to get to them as
soon as that's dead I'm more than happy
to sort of get that but I can't with all
the other people that are involved in
this project I don't feel right to just
do that and then other times like the
director that I know is trying to like
get into this proof with this producer
I've already gone everywhere I can with
this producer you know to network with
them if I can get this woman a job why
does it hurt me if she can get a job so
I do the introduction and you know it
doesn't hurt me and I find that the more
I'm willing to help people it always
comes back there's just just at whatever
level you know I think that's the I
think it's it's hard for me to
understand when people ask for help and
you can see that it's you're so selfish
and so self-centered that
no there's no give anywhere there's no
like let me you know if you needed
something I would help you can do more
like you know help me with this thing
because I heard you know the thing
compared to well yeah I don't you don't
have anything to offer me but I could
still you know it's like where's an
exchange of at least thank you a real
thank you instead of you know whatever
okay cool thanks you know kind of thing
yeah it's knowing it's knowing when
someone's more of a taker and yeah but I
get that but I guess just I find that
refreshing that you want to be around
people that are gonna hold you
accountable or or that you can kind of
aspire to or whatever you know you've
done so much already but I think that's
great because that sometimes that's not
always the attitude and it's not just
that someone thinks that you've taken a
job for me it's just they haven't gotten
the job they wanted right and so it's
too painful to be around someone that
they perceive everything's going their
way yeah absolutely and and I think that
there's two things I do have a group of
friends that have sort of gone away
while I've been progressing in my career
now my career is still not where I want
it to be but just there was there was
even a time when I got to do my first
direct my first feature there were two
people that like just were there in my
life but they I could see they pulled
back like there was something about what
they sort of their decisions were sort
of taking him a different road they were
the ones that were way more talented
than me I mean both of them still are
both of them are better directors better
writers like I think they're better but
they sort of get in their own way and
you know I found myself having to pull
away because there was no sort of like
the love wasn't you know like I wanted
them to be as excited as I was for them
when they had things happening and it
wasn't I was like oh that's interesting
and now you know this is you know about
four years later and it's like those
guys are not in my life anymore and it's
tough I mean I try to keep trying then I
was at one point is like I'm the only
one texting
take this take a look what do you get
you know what I mean and then me
and then it's just like yeah you know
it's just like Oh where's the no
excitement for what we're doing together
you know so it's tough it's time in its
business I mean it's brutal yeah that's
I guess where I was trying to say it's
not just brutal in going on auditions or
pitching whatever but then the
relationships around you and that's
something that I feel like people don't
explore a lot and you know I think it's
that's great that you you put that in
your gear in your email
you